all right guys
bang bang i've got an awesome guest
today
and ian thank you so much for taking the
time to do this man
uh it's an honor to be here i'm a big
fan of yours and uh just really an honor
yeah well listen i uh i always ask
people for questions beforehand
and every once in a while i am
overwhelmed with how many people want to
know information and yesterday was one
of those times so let's uh let's not
disappoint
everyone i feel like no no pressure
all right so for the people who don't
know you let's just start off with
background kind of what did you do
before you got into micro cap stocks
well it's a it's a good question to
start off i mean all i've been
doing honestly since i was a sophomore
in college has been microcap stocks and
you know there's a long version of this
story but i'll tell you the short one
when i was a sophomore in high school
you know my parents kind of sat me down
and said you know we saved for you
twenty thousand dollars
you know since you're a baby this is
going to be used for your college
education
we want you to know now what you're
getting so you can choose where you want
to apply yourself
just know that this is all you're
getting and you can decide
and so at that point in time that was
1997 so right in the heart of the
internet technology bubble um they
introduced me to their financial advisor
opened up an account put that twenty
thousand dollars in it um i started
talking to him about small cap tech
stocks
i got really engaged with the thought of
that just like everybody else at that
environment
and just like that just like that in
that environment you know you could
throw
a dart at a bunch of technology
companies and
and made two or three excellent your
money really quickly and that's what
happened to me then and so
i caught the the greed bug if you want
to call it that in high school and then
by the time i
to make a decision on college i chose to
go to a local university one that was
less expensive and one that i could kind
of work full time as i went
so i could invest that money that i had
grew up to that point into the stock
market
so that's ultimately what i did ended up
working for an edward jones financial
advisor here locally
um was more or less a glorified
receptionist
there for for many years actually a few
years uh
lean into the the end of the technology
bubble and then
when the technology bubble burst i was
also working there
and um you know really that i learned a
couple lessons there number one that
about 120 000 that i'd grown up to that
point
ultimately fell to about 8 000 so i
learned some tough lessons with losing
money but
also you know i was more or less a
receptionist at that
financial advisor office so i was the
one taking phone
calls from you know the thousand clients
that we had and
and talking to them and they were in you
know every emotional
state that you can imagine and at that
point in time
you know i thought i was going to be a
financial advisor and going through that
experience
you know i just said this is the last
thing i want to do you know investing is
hard enough just dealing with your own
emotions let alone the emotions of
of other people and so really from that
point forward
you know i got introduced to microcaps
because some of those small cap tech
names that fell
down through the floor became micro caps
and also it kind of set me on my path of
okay i don't want to be a financial
advisor but my goal from that point
forward was to be
a full-time private investor just
managing my own capital
and that was a goal i'd set out you know
my sophomore year in college and you
know
several years later achieved that but
really my
first entre into microcap was a company
called xm satellite radio which later
merged with sirius
which i'm sure many of you have in your
cars and when i was a
when i was in college i i found out that
that company which was a microcap back
then was presenting in new york city
and i had some fake business cards made
from castle capital
talked to the conference organizer they
let me come up to new york i took a bus
um weaseled my way into a one-on-one
meeting with the ceo at the time hugh
panera of xm satellite radio
became enthralled with that story and it
was a story mainly back then and back
then
you know 40 of their shares were held
short
so everybody was betting on that company
going bankrupt um but
ultimately took that eight thousand
dollars i had left from the the crash
put it all into xm at 1.78 per share and
um this is 185 luck but they all
suddenly started signing oem agreements
with ford and gm
they refinanced their debt and
ultimately it was a huge short covering
rally that propelled that stock from
that dollar 78 to 34
in about 14 months and um you know i
tell that story
and very quickly uh on this forum but i
tell that story because that's what
got me started in microcap and it was
really that
ability to sit down with a management
team
face to face and that's what kind of
drew me into the space and
you know that was 2001 2002 and from
that point forward just kind of learned
the ropes of microcap investing
by losing my money and making it back
and losing my money and making it back
and
that's how you learn a lot of things and
that's what i did as well absolutely so
before we kind of dig into some of the
details here right
i know there's a ton of people who are
interested in public markets that are
going to listen to this but for those
that don't know what a micro cap stock
is maybe just kind of give us some
definition
sure so if we're looking at
all public equities in north america
there's approximately 20
000 stocks that trade in north america
so i'm combining
you know the u.s exchanges and also the
canadian exchanges
and if we're looking at micro cap
companies let's define that as having
market capitalizations
less than 300 million and of those 20
000 public equities in north america
approximately 50
or 10 000 of those companies are
actually these small
micro cap companies that very few people
have heard of
so that's kind of how i define the space
and i could define that down a little
bit further
in regards to my personal strategy but
that's that's kind of vaguely how you
define it
okay and then i've seen um on some of
the materials you guys have and website
and stuff like that that actually the
smallest
decile performs best and so i think this
is kind of what you're talking about
with the story around xm
um and just kind of generally why people
would be interested in these very small
market cap stocks so maybe talk a little
bit just kind of historically
how has this performed against other
types of public equities
sure so again there's ten thousand micro
caps in north america under 300 million
and uh if you ever if you actually pull
the the csrb
data um you can actually get a member of
microcap club
pulled the data and it was through i
think 2016 but
from 1927 to 2016 the smallest decile
of the public markets which was sub 114
million
uh outperformed all other market cap
classes
and by a wide margin so the smallest
decile
sub 114 million you know how
outperformed
all the other deciles since 1927
and i think it's i think something
around 17 compounded compared to 12 and
a half
which is the next highest decile so the
next highest decile is sub 500 million
um so you you really want to or at least
i have been focused
since the start of my career on the
smallest decile and the reason for that
is these companies are so small
are so illiquid that institutional
capital can't invest in these
small companies and you know it's why i
believe kind of the small
microcap ecosystem is one of the best
place
places for a small astute investor
to get call it irrational returns
because you have this structural
advantage
to where larger smarter money can't
invest in these small companies
until these companies execute and their
stocks go up and their liquidity
increases
and it allows those institutions to then
take part in these equities and so what
happens is when you have a small company
that executes
you know their stocks rise and you see
these greater and greater waves of
capital because institutional capital
can flow into them at that point in time
and then to take it a step further not
only the smallest but uh there's some
white papers done
by roger ibison called liquidity as an
investment style
so he analyzed illiquidity as a factor
in regards to performance and what he
found
going back to i believe 1971 looking at
around 3 500
public equities was actually the best
performing
companies since 1971 were the illiquid
microcap companies and believe it or not
the worst performing area to be in
was the liquid microcap company so best
performing illiquid
micro cap worst performing liquid micro
cap
and you know i think one of the reasons
there is
and i have some experience through
investing through the 2008 2009 crisis
is you know the larger micro cap the 150
to 300 million market cap area the
larger half
they're very institutionalized by that
point in time
and usually when the market or the
economy
starts to teeter and these institutions
want to take risk off
where their investors want to pull
capital out of you know what is seen as
a riskier
equity um they pull it out of those
funds out of those indices you know the
russell microcap index
and they usually get hammered really
really quickly it's just a constant
bid whacking you know when the economy
starts to suffer a little bit
and i think that's why actually you know
this history has shown that
you know liquid microcaps are some of
the worst places to invest but illiquid
is the best
yeah and so maybe help us understand um
when we're talking about a 300 to 500
million dollar company
how liquid is liquid right when you talk
about that and then how
illiquid is the illiquidity that you're
talking about are we talking about
literally hundreds of thousands of
dollars in kind of daily volume when
you're talking about illiquid and
tens of millions in the liquid side or
just kind of give us some some uh
you know milestones if you will in terms
of how you think about that
sure um i think a good way to think
about it is
let me give you kind of an example of a
typical
kind of microcap that i would invest in
let's say it's you know not to name a
name but microcap xyz
the stock is trading at a dollar 30 per
share
let's say it has a market cap of 50
million five zero
you know i would say on average that
that micro cap might trade
20 30 000 shares per day so
you know that might be 40 000 of
volume per day trading in that small
micro cap company
you know also you know there's zero
analysts covering that
there's very little institutional
ownership
a lot of times these companies are
traded on the otc
uh the otc markets not on the nasdaq or
the nyse
and so when you compare that to maybe um
a 500 million dollar market cap
company you know there you might be
looking at a five or ten dollar stock
that might be trading
you know maybe a few million dollars of
volume per day
and they probably have five or six
analysts covering them you know
not nearly as much as something like a
large cap like let's say target which
everybody knows
which probably trades around 115 dollars
per share
trades about 400 million dollars of
volume per day has
about 40 analysts covering it 1900
institutions that own it
so that kind of gives you kind of what
i'm talking about from a liquid microcap
to liquid microcap to large cap
what it kind of looks like the
difference got it and so
help me then understand uh what the
process looks like i think a lot of
people understand
um yeah there's like the angel investing
in all the private markets and venture
capital and that's pretty well
documented
uh there's also kind of what i'll
consider the both professional
and retail like large cap you know
you've got the hedge funds who kind of
have a process
uh that they're going through and a lot
of it's publicly available information
and they'll go do crazy stuff like you
know snapshots of the parking lot or
try to get the oil levels and all that
kind of stuff and then you get robin
hood type traders you know
who basically are just letting it fly
and not doing a lot of research
the micro cap space feels like it's
actually
very process driven and very different
than kind of the large cap space so just
help me understand like what does that
process look like and what are the
differences to maybe what people are
doing
in the large cap space sure
what's interesting about microcap is you
have the same types of investors
investing in these companies as you do
in the large caps and what i mean by
that is
i mean you'll find deep value investors
investing down in these small micro caps
you'll find
value investors growth investors life
science investors
uh technology investors mining year and
pretty much all those different areas of
investing you will find
down in microcap it's just that these
companies just tend to be smaller
and so everybody's process because of
that is a little bit different from
everybody
else's i would say the main difference
is that you know we're talking about
nine ten thousand micro caps in north
america
um you know there's still another metric
you know there's ten thousand micro caps
but there's still
seven thousand of them under 100 million
market cap
so a majority of them are the smaller
ones which is which is good
um and i would say that the main thing
there is you don't
you you have to do the work you know
that there's no
analyst report to pull down and do
research with
you're the one that has to actually do
the work due diligence read the filings
read the financials communicate with
management
all these things and so the process is
different
um overall but you know everybody's
process is a little bit different you
know i don't i don't use screens very
much
to find ideas but some people do you
know if they're more
kind of quantitative you know to find
look at all stocks you know under
book value or something like that um but
for the most part
you know how you find or how i find
ideas i wish i could just point to one
resource but a lot of times it's just
through brute force
research going through every micro cap
company
a through z i mean i'm actually in the
process of doing this
in the uk on the london aim exchange
looking at the the micro caps
on the the aim exchange in london
literally going through
a through z and it's very tedious
but you know it's the only way you don't
miss something a lot of times your edge
in this business is your ability and
willingness to kind of sift through a
mountain of uninvestable ideas trying to
find that needle in a haystack
so brute force is a big area of how do
you find these networking
you know just through the years of me
doing this i have personal relationships
i talk to people i talk to every week on
the phone
people that invest similar to me um
people that invest differently than me
you know just trying to see what people
like
you know when i was starting in microcap
all the activity
uh around these smaller micro caps was
on public message boards
like raging bull yahoo finance investors
hub
and now that's kind of gravitated to
seeking alpha and some private forums
just like you know microcap club.com
which uh which i founded
and so you're you can find valuable
discussions there you're just looking at
prs filings
i do sometimes do screens i don't find
them very useful
um you know serendipity you know just
stumbling on on an idea just keeping
your eyes and ears open
uh but those are primary areas to find
ideas
um you know you have to use all of those
tactics to try to find these
these companies and that's that's what
we're trying to do here i mean we're i'm
trying to find
great companies early you know i'm not a
deep value investor
i have don't have a willingness to want
to buy something that's undervalued that
will stay undervalued i want to find
something that's undervalued that can
get overvalued
and that's primarily what i'm looking
for and but that might be different from
other people that are
even successful you know in the microcap
arena i know a lot of successful deep
value investors
that that have have an incredible
performance so that's
that's how we'd find them and then you
know when when you go to analyzing
the ideas everybody kind of analyzes
differently some people don't believe
that management
is important to talk to well i take the
other side of that and i believe
management is very important to talk to
because you know the smaller the company
the more important management becomes
you know a lot of times these ceos
aren't just the ceo they're the mark of
the chief marketing officer they're
taking the trash out
they make the coffee in the morning you
know they they wear a lot of hats and so
you want to make sure
that the person leading that company uh
you know is the right person
so you know in addition to that you know
a lot of it
microcap gets a bad rap because
of a lot of the headlines you'll read
about micro caps also known as penny
stocks
is you know some of the bad stuff that
happens yes there's some fraudulent
companies
down in this arena yes there's companies
that probably shouldn't be public but i
would say there's
you know there's probably far less a
percentage of the whole than when
compared to
private equity or venture capital um so
and the information that's available to
investors so when you're analyzing this
does this look like you get your s1s and
10ks kind of all the traditional public
filings that a large cap company would
do
or is there some different type of
information that is available or not
available
for most of the micro caps they file
with the sec
they have audited financials if they
don't
many of them and i would say
let's call it 70 80 of micro caps
they're just like looking at google
where they file their financials
on sec.gov you can look through them
you can find that information and you
can have
some comfort in the fact that there they
are audited financials then there's also
some other ones that don't file with the
sec but they still file audited
financials
on otcmarkets.com and then there's
another level
lower than that which you know i try to
tell people to stay away from there's
those are companies that actually don't
report anything and they're kind of the
dark
the dark companies um and so you know i
get last a lot you know if i want to get
into this space what should i focus on
and i tell people you know if you want
to really get rid of a lot of the risk
you know focus
on the companies that are filing with
the sec and focus on the companies that
are actually making a profit
um about 18 of all the micro caps are
profitable
so you'll feel you know save yourself a
lot of pain if you just focus on the
profitable ones
when you start yeah and to me this feels
like and i've joked with people before
uh micro cap investing is very similar
to
venture capital investing it's just a
different type of company has likely
chosen to go the venture capital route
versus the type of company that's chosen
to get into the public markets early in
its life cycle
and so how do you look at that um
difference or similarities between micro
cap investing kind of
you know let's go kind of lowest decile
so kind of sub 115 million
to maybe kind of series a series b type
venture capital investing
well you know we could probably spend a
whole podcast just talking about this
but maybe the first thing i'll say is
you know it when you're looking at small
companies whether it's private equity
venture capital and then there's
small public companies and everybody
loves to glorify venture capital
everybody loves to glorify
small private equity everybody likes to
beat up on old microcap
you know as an investment class and you
know a lot of people forget that
you know some of the best investors ever
started here you know warren buffett
peter lynch joel greenblatt they all
started in these small microcap
companies it's just that their net worth
grew
and they grew out of investing in this
class you know the best companies
ever like walmart netflix celgene
intuitive surgical
they were micro-cap companies you know
berkshire hathaway was even a micro-cap
when buffett took it over
on an inflation-adjusted basis you know
the best performing companies
ever started out of microcap you know
and so all these great investors all
these great companies all these great
returns came out of microcap and yet
i'm guessing that a lot of people never
heard of them and uh you know it's a
shame because the most powerful force at
least in public markets
is the discovery phase of a great
business when it's small
you know and that's and that's what
we're looking at and so you know i
it's a big reason why i'm active on
social media it's not because i've
want to pull people into any of my
brands because a lot of what i do is
capacity constrained it's mainly
just to keep the light shining on this
space
you know um so when we
look and compare them to kind of private
equity
you know here it it really changes
geography based like here in the us
uh historically and a lot of people
don't talk about this either anthony a
lot of people talk about the decline in
public companies
you know over the last 20 years well
a lot of that decline i think really
started
aggressively happening in 2010 and the
reason for that
is you had a lot of reverse mergers
happening pre-2010 a lot of
then the china frauds occurred kind of
2010 2011
and so that really cut down on the
amount of reverse mergers that are
happening
and so up until 2010 we averaged 800
reverse mergers a year
so 800 companies going public a year as
micro caps
and yes maybe 90 of them you know went
away or shouldn't have been public or
whatever but it's kind of the law of
large numbers you know a certain
percentage of them would have graduated
up into small cap
you know became listed and since 2010
that 800 of years went down to about a
hundred
so you know it's a really big falloff
and i think that's been impacting
the public markets as well um and those
companies when they went public
i mean you're talking about a company
that would raise that had the ability to
raise a million
two billion three million and then just
go public you're not talking about 20
million
30 million dollars you're trying to be
small you know raises um and really
since 2010
kind of the microcap in the u.s has been
kind of on a downdraft i would say but
the opposite can be said in places like
canada
and australia to where they still have
very active micro-cap markets where
they're going public
raising five 10 million and going public
because they don't have
as robust of a venture capital or
private equity scene as we do down here
in the united states
as well um and their populists mean
they're very resource centric in
australia and canada
they're they're not as risk-averse as we
are down here
and you know it's hard to find a
canadian citizen that doesn't own a
you know junior exploration company in
canada or something like that
and so it's just a very it's a much more
active scene in those two geographies
compared to
the us um i don't know if that helps
answer your question
no no it does and how do you think about
portfolio construction right so
our mutual friend adam singer said to
ensure that i ask you about uh kind of
concentrated bets versus diversification
and he said you had kind of a lot of
thoughts around um especially since
you're investing in
um a sector of the market where uh
you're not gonna kind of get the you
know eight percent growth year-over-year
and
and really what you're looking for is a
company that's small today like you said
that they can kind of grow into
something much much larger over time so
how do you think about diversification
versus concentrated investments
well you know kind of first when i talk
when i when i talk about microcap
it's probably similar to how you would
may not want to put words in your mouth
but it's probably how you would talk
about bitcoin for you
where it's like you're not telling
people to go 100 you know into
and it's kind of what i say with
microcap you know i'm a little bit of an
oddball you know
this is all i know how to do and so you
know 95 of my assets are in micro cap
companies and that sounds completely
deranged to most people
uh but i you know i tell other people
you know this is kind of something where
you look at
your portfolio and can you devote five
percent
three percent whatever percent to these
small growing emerging companies and i
think that probably makes a lot of sense
to most people
you know to get to get this appetite
into their portfolio
um as it relates to my portfolio
construction it's it's actually evolved
quite a bit over the years so
you know when i was building my capital
um in the early 2000s
so i went right from undergrad graduated
there 2003 went right to graduate
school at villanova until 2005
and then i worked for a small ir firm
for six months then started my own
little firm
and basically i was just trying to cover
my expenses until my portfolio grew to a
size
where i could just quit all of that and
just manage my own portfolio full time
and that's what i didn't know eight
um 2008 in the depths of the crisis
and but while i was doing that while i
was building that capital i
i was in three or four companies i was
very
super concentrated um and i was willing
to take
that type of risk make those types of
bets and so it was not unusual to see 50
of you know my net worth in one company
and it's not something i advise other
people to do
but it's just how i did it um and then
as my portfolio has grown
in size you know i've become a little
bit more diversified but i'm still
talking about a dozen equities
you know which again most people would
still say is
insanely concentrated but that seems
very diversified to me
um and usually what happens with my own
portfolio today
is you know i'll usually take a position
at to 5 10 at cost
and then let it run you know where
before i would probably take it
up to 25 or 30 percent like right away
you know what i've what i realized over
the years
is you know it makes sense to buy a
little a little bit wait for these
management teams to prove themselves
you know and then don't be afraid to
average up some of my biggest winners
over the years have been coming coming
from averaging up
into a good situation not constantly
averaging down and something that's
disappointing you
um and so that's that's a little bit how
my portfolio has evolved so today you
know i'll let something get up to maybe
30
of the portfolio a single position then
i'll start just start shaving it back a
little bit
you know 25 let it go to 30 again shave
it back to 25
you know that type of thing and usually
the ones that i keep it
five percent to start that aren't
exactly performing i don't add to them
very often
you know i want to let the companies
that become larger my portfolio have
earned the right
and the companies that don't have it
that's kind of how i view my portfolio
construction
yeah it's really interesting because
you're hitting on two key
themes that i think everyone likes to
talk about but it's really hard to do
and people get nervous when uh
forced to do it but the first is our
concentration builds wealth and
diversification protects it right and
this is kind of tried and true over the
years
investors in all kinds of different
sectors kind of all talk about that
which you just did and then the second
thing is this idea of
the best investors are really pressing
their winners right so it's
kind of an average to good investor will
make a small investment it'll go up
three times
uh you know three x and all of a sudden
they're like you know i hit a triple
but the best investor actually sees that
and has conviction that hey this is
going to go up 15
times or 20 times and they'll start
adding to the position even though it's
already gone up 3x and kind of just
averaging up
and just really pressing into hey i i
was right
right and i think i'm going to continue
to be right and not being afraid to kind
of
pay up more for a company uh in the
future
as they've actually earned kind of to
your point the right to have that new
valuation
on their path to you know what could be
higher gains
yeah it exactly especially it depends on
how you invest like i said
i'm trying to find companies a lot of
times at the inflection point of
profitability
and so you know a 10 bagger in my world
is something that is
losing money breaks even and starts
making money
you know and that can happen over a few
quarters or a few years
but you know something that loses 10
cents a share to breaks even to earns 10
cents
over a year or two you know that's a 10x
you know and so the further back you go
into that unprofitable camp the more
risk you have in the smaller position i
usually make it at the onset
and once that reaches profitability and
once they prove themselves more and they
get to profitability
that's when you kind of a place to
really press your bet if you will or you
just leave it you don't devote more
capital to it you just let it alone
though you know you let it grow as a
percentage of the portfolio which is
what i also do um but usually at the
onset what i
i got lucky kind of early in my career
when i was really building capital in a
couple ideas where i pressed the bet
hard out of the gate and i ended up
being right
and that works when you're right you
know and it doesn't work when you're
not right and so now i kind of eased
back a little bit
make a smaller investment and just i'm
much more active to add
add to that position now how has the
pandemic changed the way that you look
at investing in this sector
or maybe it hasn't changed anything at
all but like what's been
kind of your experience over the last
couple of months as the pandemic and
then the economic recession
you know in microcap it's been a little
bit bifurcated where
the microcaps that trade in the nasdaq
and the new york stock exchange
because the the russell indices have
been ripping you know they've been
having that tail
that that constant inflows coming into
those
those equities and so the listed micro
caps have really done well
it really outperformed and i'm finding a
lot of the ones that are in the otc
again the ones that aren't
institutionalized you know that that
aren't in those indices that aren't in a
lot of
microcap funds you know haven't had
those same tailwinds so a lot you can
still kind of find value
you know if you will down there and so
that's one of the dynamics i've been
seeing even my portfolio today which is
probably
50 50 listed companies versus otc the
otc ones are
definitely underperforming the ones that
are that are listed
right now but you know kind of how my
portfol
what i generally look for is four main
things when i look at a company
um and this has evolved over the years
but i'm you know even before
covid you know i'm looking for a
business that can grow through a
recession
you know and so you immediately take 10
000 micro caps you just put that filter
on it it probably takes it down to eight
percent of that ecosystem
you know and then i'm looking for a
balance sheet that can weather a storm
you know so it can act with occasional
boldness you know during
a recessionary period you know that
takes you know that eight percent
of the ten thousand companies down to
probably five or four percent and then
you're looking for a stock that can
conservatively double
based off fundamental underpinnings over
the two or three year
time period and then i'm looking for an
organization that has
what i believe is kind of that
intelligent fanatic type leadership
and so those are kind of the four
filters that i
put on top of every every new thing i
look at um
and just not that many companies fall
out the bottom of that funnel and that
first one
a business that can grow through a
recession you know that gives you a lot
of comfort
even in a coveted environment um that
you're investing in these quality
types of businesses or situations and
yeah i mean just like what we're seeing
in large cap
a lot of them are tech centric um but
that you're in these situations that can
do well and not only do well they have a
balance sheet to acquire a competitor or
whatever the case may be
and so that's kind of how i look at what
i'm looking for you know and the microps
i invested
so it would uh be obvious i think to a
lot of people to say
um why are investors not taking
positions for small dollars
uh and trying to take these companies
private right they're so small
they're already somewhat illiquid is
there a business in doing that
have people tried that before has it not
worked have you thought about it just
talk to me about kind of this idea of
you've got a small cap stock that
wouldn't require nearly as much capital
as let's say a very large cap stock
and kind of bringing them back into the
private markets
you you definitely see that you know
i've probably been contacted
a dozen times over the last three years
from
private equity firms that manage you
know
10 billion plus that that want to do
exactly that
you know just like everything else it's
a lot harder than it looks but we're
you're seeing that let me give you an
example so microcap club.com
which is basically a membership site
people just talk about what ideas they
like and why
we have 600 companies microcap companies
that have been profiled by our members
on there that
kind of gets the discussion started and
people talk about them and follow them
and
um you know some of them aren't active
threads you know some kind of go away
but a lot of them are active
you know of those 600 companies since
2011 that have been profiled and
discussed on my hair cap club
i think we're up to 92 of those
companies have been acquired
so 92 of the 600 so that's a decent
percentage of that and not all that's
private equity you know some of that's
just
a private company buying a public
company you know and and you're starting
to see that where you're seeing private
company valuations get to a point where
it's actually more
prudent for them to buy a public small
company
um in some of these cases so we are
seeing a lot of m a activity
you know start to heat up especially in
the last couple of years i would say
and i guess as you think about the micro
cap space
uh you are um one of kind of the most
vocal people about it you always have
this deep-seated belief
what would need to change in the market
with companies
uh maybe structurally on the economy for
you to basically throw your hands up and
say
you know what i had my run this was
great but i'm gonna go and
focus on venture capital i'm gonna go
focus on you know large cap stocks or
just do something else other than micro
cap like
what would kind of be that uh inflection
point or that lever that you would just
kind of throw your hands up and say you
know
it's not worth my time it'd be worth
doing something better
um with my capital and energy
i don't think i don't think i could ever
see myself doing that just because i'm
i'm not in 100 companies and i don't
need to find 15 companies a year
you know i'm in a dozen and if i can
find one or two good situations a year
that's all it takes and i think it's
become it has become more important
for an investor to not be landlocked to
their geography so
you know you're not just focusing on u.s
microcaps you're also focusing on
canadian
you're focusing on the uk you're
focusing on australia and i mentioned
those three just because they're english
speaking with similar accounting rules
uh it's becoming more important that you
become more of a worldwide investor
and so i don't ever really see that
happening i mean it's pretty bad here in
the us but
i still find you know a half a dozen
ideas a year probably that fit those
four filters i told you about
that are really good situations so
i love that answer um what is the
process
uh you go through in terms of when you
you mentioned talking to the management
teams is a
a key piece for you what are you looking
for
what are the questions you're asking um
and kind of how does that differ then
maybe
again a venture capitalist or a large
cap investor if they got to sit down
with the ceo
like what is specific to the micro cap
sector
uh in those conversations with
management or ceos
i would say it's very similar to what
vcs and
private equity go through i talked to
brent b shore quite frequently about
this
and i say i would say it's very similar
to the types of conversations
the only kind of differences from those
types of conversations when they're
private versus small companies when
they're public is
you do want to get a sense for how they
feel about dilution how they would raise
capital if they had to
because unlike those markets like
private equity and venture capital
there's not a lot of good sources of
capital for small public companies
um a lot of the the service providers
that are in this arena
you know they'll give you two million
dollars of capital but they'll also
dilute you 40
and and um you know it'll just
it's such a it'll be confident it's just
a bad situation for a lot of small
companies but
so a lot of the conversations i have
with management is just
kind of seeing what their capital
markets iq is
and um and talking to them about that
so a lot of people want to know your
thoughts on um
bitcoin cryptocurrency uh and then also
in the precious metal space
with both the actual assets themselves
and then like gold miners
maybe let's start with uh the gold and
gold miners like
how do you look at precious metals then
how do you look at maybe some of the
micro
cap stocks that are related to those
precious metals
in 2000 let's see five six you know i
was heavily invested
in kind of junior exploration mining
precious metals companies
and so there's a good two or three year
period of time where i was solely
focused on this arena
and um you know i i probably got a
little bit lucky
during that time period as well but you
know i still
invest in that area and what i try to
focus on are
companies that actually have production
of gold or precious metals not
just the ones that are exploring for
them um you know and so
the the ones that i'm investing in today
are they have actual gold mines they're
they're operating
and what you find over time is some of
the biggest discoveries that have
happened
you know don't actually come from
exploration companies they come from
people that are already mining that are
drilling out that are
you know that they're getting mon
they're going deeper deeper underground
in the mine and they're just stumbling
upon
the next million ounces it's not coming
from somebody drilling 50
50 grid pattern holes through the
surface you know
in a small micro cap company so i'm i
mainly focus on producers
because i think historically they have
found the biggest kind of paydays
on on new resources and
i also try to find those that have an
operator running the business that have
had a history of success that looks at
mining and their business like a
business
not just a promote or a stock to get up
and raise more capital
so i'm really looking for business
operators that look at their
you know mining as a real business not
as somebody just running a promote for a
stock
yeah and i guess how do you kind of um
pull that out
right like what are the signals that
you're looking for that can kind of
highlight that because i think when you
say it like it makes sense
right obviously doing it is much harder
so kind of what's the process like or
what are you exactly looking for there
you know just like everything else it
just takes a lot of work to get to know
the founder and the ceo of the company
to see who they really are it's just
like any relationship
whether it's with your wife or or
whatever you know
it's hard to build that trust overnight
just in a conversation or two you know
and so a lot of
my time is spent having conversations
with a lot of ceos to see who they truly
are
you know and i've been lucky enough with
a few in the mining area
that had previous successes they you
know had took companies from very small
to
larger and just got to know them well
and i continue to make those bets on
those same individuals
but it just takes a lot of work to just
kind of start trying to see who somebody
really is i mean a lot of is just kind
of common sense a lot of ways
um you know i'm looking at somebody
that's that's constantly telling me
about the business not constantly
telling me about the stock
and is it common for a micro cap ceo
to do two three four different
um kind of endeavors throughout their
career or do you see most of these ceos
staying with one business for
you know a decade or two you know you
see
kind of serial entrepreneurs of microcap
from time to time
a lot of times what you'll also see is
somebody that started started their
micro cap
you know in the 1980s and they're still
running it today and they shouldn't be
you know so just because they've been
around for a long time doesn't mean they
should still be there
and it's probably a good spot for
activism to take place
uh you know but primarily you you know i
do like to try to find people that have
previous success
i'm not drawn to i'm not drawn to people
that have
big company success you know it doesn't
impress me if they ever the president at
ibm
because you know it doesn't really help
you when you run a small company on a
shoestring budget
you know i'm gonna see entrepreneurial
success
yeah that makes sense um and then
bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies have you done any
work there kind of what are your
thoughts in general
about that entire space i know very
little about it to be honest with you
and i'm not ashamed to admit that but
you know i kind of view it like i do
gold and silver that has a slice of my
portfolio
you know to where it probably it
probably does make sense to devote some
you know some fraction of your portfolio
to something like this you know but you
would be much more
uh better to to talk to about this than
me i'm a big fan of not opening my mouth
when i know what i'm going to say is
going to make people dumber
so but i think i do find it interesting
right because
um one of the things that just talking
to you uh
is very obvious is like the things that
you're looking at are
uh innovative in nature because any time
that you've got something that is
small in value today and you hope will
grow to be much larger in value in the
future there has to be some level of
innovation
right and people will debate you know
what's more innovative than not and kind
of
what's sustainable what's not but at the
end of the day that's what you're really
looking for you're looking for who can
go into a market and capture market
share and drive financials
and i think that crypto is very similar
now it probably has a much more
binary bet to it right or kind of
outcome where it's either gonna all be
really really valuable and that's gonna
be you know kind of the the um
product of these like promises it's
gonna be as big as the internet and you
know that type of
uh perspective or it's gonna kind of be
you know uh kind of clean tech space
in the mid 2000s right where like they
had a bunch of excitement and then it
kind of didn't really produce anything
and people lost money
and so to me it's like has a lot of the
ingredients of
the companies that you look at but has a
much more binary outcome like
i'm not sure how many micro caps go to
zero every year i'm sure there's some
but probably not nearly as many as you
know
the alt coins at the bottom you know 2
000 that are all likely to go to zero
for example
yeah i mean probably maybe the the
better it probably is somewhat like
microcap but it's probably more so like
venture capital
you know maybe in that in that to those
extremes you know where 60
of the companies go to zero you know i'm
not sure what it is but i think i think
you're right i think it's probably very
similar
there might even be i don't know how
many how much crypto is out there now
but if there's
you know 500 a thousand more than that
but probably the numbers are probably
even similar
um and it just it's probably the same
due diligence process too tom
shaughnessy has been beating me over the
head about crypto and bitcoin for so
many years and i was like tom leave me
alone one of these days i'm just gonna
have to
find find you know i got to educate
myself a little bit more on this like
get on a podcast like this and not sound
like an idiot
but i think you're right
don't don't let tom get in your ear man
he'll get you
[Laughter]
i love it uh when i asked people for
questions one of the most popular
questions was just like
what was the uh best investment and what
was the worst investment you've ever
made
so maybe kind of give us some details
there in terms of uh kind of
both the process and then the outcomes
on best and worst investment
sure um one that since we were talking
about precious metals one of
one of the big winners i have was a was
a company
called gold resource corporation still
trade today and
they went public in 2006 at an ipo at a
dollar
you know so a dollar per share by a 25
million market cap company
and this is 2006 and they own some
property down to mexico they wanted to
develop into a mine
and they just approached the business
completely i may say just ask backwards
from everybody else in mining
they said we're not going to sit here
and waste 10 years and 200 million
dollars drilling out a resource
we know this resource is there we're
going to drill out you know enough to
make a production decision and we're
going to get this thing into production
in
five years and the industry just kind of
laughed at them they're like okay
whatever
you know because it usually takes 20
years to get something into production
um and so they
long story short they pulled it off you
know by 2010 so 2006 2010
they actually got into production and
their goal from the very beginning
their story you know they went until the
story from when they ipo'd was we're
going to do this by this date no
everybody said yeah right and by the way
we're going to be a low-cost producer
our average cost is you know 300
an ounce let's say on our on our gold
that we produce
and how we're going to spend that cash
flow as a third to taxes a third to
exploration a third is a dividend
and if we get our production up to this
rate we think we can pay a dollar per
share dividend
and everybody's like yeah whatever you
know uh yeah sure
well they made into production by 2010
and i think it was by 2011
2012 they hit a dollar per share in a
dividend
you know and that stock ultimately went
from a dollar to 30 you know in about
five years
and they paid a massive dividend and i
sold too early you know i think i sold
out around 9
10 something like that and it still
kicked me because i remember when they
paid that dollar dividend i'm like i
could have just got this dividend and
just
you know went on an island or something
you know uh
but it was an incredible story and then
they had their ups and downs because the
the precious metals industry kind of had
its ups and downs but they're still
around today
but that's uh that was a very
fascinating story and i just loved it
because they approached the industry
completely different
um they were kind of mavericks in that
regard and they pulled it off
so it goes back to uh doing something
different than everybody else if you're
right usually ends up leading to
incredible value creation if you uh end
up being wrong though you're just the
idiot in the room
right yeah exactly yeah what's the
outcome is an important part
exactly on the bad side um
i think it was the investment i made
right after that
and i don't know if you tend to if you
see this in your career anthony but
a lot of times the worst decisions you
make is right after a big win because
you're in a gunslinging mood you're like
oh yeah i'll throw money at this or that
the other thing
and that was kind of one of these
situations so i ended up investing in a
company right after that
that um again long story short it
ultimately
was a fraud like they were cooking the
books and it was a company that had good
fundamentals actually had good
financials but
i never quite understood why somebody
would actually buy the product
you know but the numbers were going up
and to the right every quarter you know
they were reporting
and it ultimately i woke up one morning
the the stock was halted
um the auditor couldn't find the cash
that the company supposedly said they
had
uh it opened back up 50 lower i sold
then you know and then it ultimately
went down to zero in about two months
and that was one of the biggest um one
of the biggest losses i took
and you know i learned a couple valuable
lessons there you know mainly from
not investing in companies that have
products or services that you don't
completely believe in
yeah what other lessons did you learn
from something like that because i think
when people
lose money that's actually when they
learn the most so obvious in terms of
uh what you just said but what other
lessons do you think you took away from
it
um i think one of the other lessons
believe it or not this might not be what
you're looking for
but is that you're not going to be
right all the time in this business and
you hear that a lot
you know but especially i find that a
lot of people actually hurt their
returns by trying to be perfect
by trying to find the perfect situation
but oftentimes the best opportunities
are the situations that aren't perfect
yet
and so you're trying to find these
things that aren't squeaky clean
quite yet you know you're betting that
they will be
um and so one of the lessons was trying
not to
let that situation like that completely
take away
my courage to make another investment
in something that's not perfect so i
continue
to make choices make investments into
things where i know
in the 12 companies that i hold i'm
going to be wrong on probably five or
six of these
and so a lot of my time and attention is
spent on the ones that could i could be
wrong on
you know where am i going to be roaming
these you know the winners are kind of
easy they execute they put up the
numbers their stocks go up
but you know compounding money is about
time
interest and time you know just being in
these things for a long time
but the other side of that is make sure
you don't lose money you know so i want
to keep my losses small let my winners
run kind of
build a neal quote and how do you think
about
selling positions right so you've got a
concentrated portfolio you have to have
high conviction when you put these
positions on
what are the things you've learned over
time or maybe some processes you have in
terms of being
confident enough to say look i was wrong
or something changed and i'm going to go
ahead and cut this position
what does that look like for you you
know usually
you know so i have a system set up with
every one of my investments where
you know each one of these companies and
this is probably where it's changed too
where i told you i was in three or four
companies when i was kind of building
capital
and i was on top of those companies and
what i realized
just through maturing as an investor is
i don't need to have my hands on top of
all the variables in that company
there's probably three or four main ones
you know that i need to be a tune of
that matter you know for the long run
and so for each one of my the companies
i'm invested in i know what those two or
three variables are
and then i just put in safety nets
everywhere to try to pick up on clues
that the story might be changing
you know it might be just you know using
google with
keywords you know or it might be
you know just tracking the conversations
that i have with management not that
they're
telling me anything that they shouldn't
but just the tone difference in a
conversation
it's amazing just how you can just spot
a tone difference in the conversation
with a ceo that you've talked to a
hundred times before and you're like you
know something's wrong here it's not
that he told me anything
just that i can tell the enthusiasm has
changed
and i would say 50 of the stocks that i
sold you know were just because of
some when there's soft cues like that
you know
and that's why it's hard to do with this
business and do or do what i do
and how invest how i do without having
that kind of relationship
not with management but just kind of
just having that communication line
you know so you so you can have that to
see that and again not like they're
telling you anything it's just
you get to know somebody and you can
tell when something's different
and in all the times when i spotted or
thought that something changed and i
didn't sell
i should have sold you know
like every time and so usually when you
start rationalizing owning a position is
when you should sell immediately
that's a pretty good piece of advice
talk to me a little bit about
microcapclub.com and then intelligent
fanatics
capital management like what are you
guys doing uh
the capital management side and then uh
in terms of microcap club.com
sure so i became a full-time private
investor
in 2000 late 2008 and 2009
and i had my own blog at that point time
where i was talking about the handful of
ideas that i liked
and quite honestly it was just getting
too much attention you know i was in
these small liquid equities you know
every time i post on something it would
you know
shoot the stock up which is great for
your ego but it's just not
a good long-term business thing to have
you know the powers that be don't like
that type of
you know manipulation if you want to
call it that and i just said you know i
don't like this let's shut it down so i
shut down my blog
and i but i really enjoyed talking about
ideas seeing what other people liked
and i saw what value investors club was
doing and a couple other
websites were doing and i said why don't
we just combine that and create a
private community
of like-minded experienced micro-cap
investors that
is shielded from the public that's
private where we can kind of just talk
about what we like
and why and so launch that site in 2011
um
and i thought hey if nobody else joins
this thing it'll just be my own personal
diary
you know whatever it'll still be a good
tool or resource for me
uh and it was it was mainly probably
just me talking to myself for the first
year
but over time we attracted people into
it and
you know we have about 250 members now
from across the world
about 40 from outside north america and
you know we talk about stock or
microcaps in not only
the us but canada australia the uk uh
kind of expanding out a little bit more
and more every year
and it's just a great resource for
finding ideas it's not
this it's not a website so you can
become a member it's free
all you have to do is submit your
favorite micro cap idea two page
investment thesis
uh the membership votes on the quality
level of that investment thesis every
month
um if you get enough votes you get in if
you don't you don't so we average
10 or 15 people that apply a month you
know maybe three or four get in
um and that's just how it's been and
then we're constantly pruning out
members that don't participate
so we're always around this 200 to 250
but it's a very core group
of folks and it's very active group and
then we also have the ability
if you don't have the time or the or the
ability to actually produce an idea
you can just subscribe for 500 bucks a
year and get view only access of these
conversations that we're having
but where it's a little bit different is
you know this is not a guru service this
is not
oh come look at ian he turned ten
thousand to seven million look at me
you know it's not that at all it's
mainly you know you want to see what a
bunch of smart people in this space are
looking at why
that's why you know you join a site like
this as a subscriber
uh i i love the idea of applying
and having to meet a certain quality
threshold voted on by the members
right i mean like there's no better uh
kind of um
you know insurance that hey the people
who are joining this are going to be the
people we want here
and also uh kind of fit the quality that
we need to keep this valuable
yeah yeah and a lot of times the cool
thing about microcap is
everybody's different you know we have a
lot of young investors
and you know a lot of because these are
small companies you know
they're mainly found by retail you know
i say there's like a there's kind of a
maturation of
of the investor base in an evolving
company it's like small retail
small institution large institution
and dumb retail at the end um and so we
have a lot of younger investors
and you know i you know a lot of people
they they might apply and they're a 200
billion dollar fund manager another
person might have five thousand dollars
to their name
you know and we don't care as long as
you're smart and you find good things
and you post good content you know
there's a place for you to be a member
yeah i love that and then on the capital
management side
yeah so you know i can't i can't say i'm
a full-time private investor anymore
you know per se is at that definition
but you know basically i've always said
no
to matching other people's money for a
lot of years mainly because of that
experience i had working for that
financial advisor during the dot-com
crash
i didn't feel like dealing with other
people you know you just say no
year after year and you say no just
because you've always said no and then
you finally
you finally meet the right people that
you said okay you know maybe this person
can invest alongside me
you know and um you know it's just
because i'm getting
into my upper 30s now you know but you
know maybe there's more to life than me
sitting in my corner office for the next
20 years by myself you know maybe i can
help some other people
you know get access to this amazing
ecosystem and so that's
where i kind of sat down and talked to
my wife about it and we decided that it
was a good time to you know see if we
could do this
kind of form a capital management firm
and give people access
to the smaller half of the microcap
ecosystem which is very few
intelligent ways to do that you know you
can buy the russell microcap index but
the average market cap is a small cap
you know and they own 1400 names you
know the worst
the worst way to own microcap is to own
all of them you know this is a stock
pickers market
you know so uh but the downside of this
is it's capacity constrained
you know like what i'm doing will never
be a 200 million dollar
fund because there's just only you know
especially if i own a dozen companies
that are
averaging 50 million market cap it just
doesn't work
so you know so we have this capital
management firm where i manage
i don't know maybe 30 or 40 other
families you know alongside my capital
you know but i'm not really bringing any
new capital because it's a capacity
constrained thing that i do and i'd
rather just grow their net worth with
mine rather than
just try to raise as much money as i can
yeah and what's interesting to me is
because of that capacity constraint
i'm assuming that there's families or
you know lps that you have where they
would love to give you
more money but you probably can't take
as much either like you're
actually taking a smaller piece of
somebody's net worth just because you
have that capacity constraint right
yeah i mean in fact when i launched it i
actually had a maximum investment people
could do which nobody does that
you know so it's just like it's a
hundred thousand minimum 200 000 max of
them they're like well
what if i want to give you a million
like no you know i'm sorry you know and
a lot of that was due to you know some
of the people that are
investing with me i didn't know them
very long
you know and so it was a way to protect
the other investors you know the first
thing i do in this
when when i talk to investors just try
to scare the crap out of them
like this is volatile you know if the
market's down 40 i'm gonna be down 50.
you know
can you handle that and if you can't
this isn't for you and
you let them self-select back in you
know be like you know if they call me
back and be like no i want to hear more
about this
you know i know i found the right
investor and
so it's been a lot of time just trying
to find the right investors to invest
alongside me because i don't want to go
through a cove in 19
february and march and people calling up
complaining about their stock portfolio
being down
and that's the time when you should be
you know adding to something
um and you know because we had the right
investors that's what that's what
occurred
i was going to say what was the
situation like uh in february march this
year
it was it was actually really good i was
i was very pleased i mean probably a
quarter of the people called up and said
all right i'm ready to put more you know
i didn't have to initiate anything
either you know so it was
we have a good core group of folks and
you know just like in any asset
management business
i mean the investors themselves should
always outperform the average because
they should be buying
when it's opportunistic to buy an ad you
know and that's what i try to tell
people out of the gate as well
i love that before we wrap up uh i
always ask the same two questions to
everybody
uh the first one is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
um
[Music]
i would say maybe there's a couple of
them
the first is is the bible you know and
whether you believe in in jesus or not i
think it's just a great book and how to
live a fulfilled life and a great life
and obviously
talk about money and finances quite a
bit i think over 800 times
but i think it's just a great book for
anybody to pick up and read and gain
some valuable lessons the second book
was think and grow rich by napoleon hill
it was a book i read when i was 16 years
old that kind of got me on the path that
i'm on today
you know when i was 16 i thought i was
going to be kind of stuck managing my
family's business at the time which was
not my passion in life
and it kind of gave me the courage to to
do something else
and so i i talked about that book maybe
a a quick third book that i
that probably people haven't read is a
book called free capital by guy thomas
and it's a story of 12 private full-time
investors who
took their net worth from zero up to
millions
and you know the reason why kind of this
book impacted me
is you know i read it a few years after
i became a full-time private investor
and it occurred to me you know there's
so few books written about
full-time private investing i mean we
read books quite honestly all the time
about you know people that
build up huge amount of wealth you know
using the float of others
you know basically fund managers or
asset managers um
but i believe honestly that being a
full-time private investor is probably
the pinnacle of financial achievement
because you don't need anybody
you don't need clients you need
customers you don't you can just
do what you do and i think that's an
amazing thing to be able to achieve
and there's very few people um that
i can say very few but there's very few
books devoted to it because these types
of full-time private investors that are
even talked about
in this book they're private you know
they're they don't want people to know
who they are you know one of my
one of my mentors um
when i probably in the mid 2000's i met
him he was a
he was a gentleman that he worked a
regular job
and he took his uh 200 000 401 k in 1990
and he's micro cap investor and i don't
know two years ago it's probably worth
75 million you know from 200 000 and
it's
strictly in a concentrated microcap but
you'd never know it you know he still
lives in a 400
000 house still lives where he still
works the same job because he loves his
job
you know and it's important to him when
you talk to him he's just like my worst
nightmare is people you know my
friends my family actually know what i'm
worth you know they'll start looking at
me differently
you know they they'll start looking at
me for what i have
not the relationships that we have and
so it's important
that anonymity is important to him
and not only that i think a lot of
private full-time investors they found a
niche
that they can exploit for a long time
there's no reason to arm wave and bring
people to it
and so those two are kind of combination
why kind of full-time private investing
is sort of like this little
thing that people talk about but nobody
wants to really talk about
you know unless it's anonymously and so
this book you know talks about 12 of
these people and some of them are
anonymous some of them aren't
and the other thing i liked about this
book is not everybody is investing the
same way there's commodities traders
there's short-term traders there's
investors there's people doing different
things
and i think that's a valuable lesson for
everybody you know listening to this
you know there's a lot of ways to to get
wealthy in this world you know you don't
need to invest like buffett you don't
need an investor like
anthony or me you know you can find your
own path that
that really connects with who you are
and then that's when you just crush it
and focus on it
i love that story it is uh the epitome i
think
of uh of freedom too right like you said
so
that's awesome uh second question is a
little bit more fun one and then you're
gonna get to ask me a question to end it
but
uh aliens believer or non-believer
i don't know i i never even thought
about that one before
you've never thought about it well i've
thought about it but i've never thought
about it deep enough to
ah so i had a guy come on the podcast
once uh yeah this bruce fenton and he
said
every human asks the same two questions
at some point in their life one what
happens after we die
and two are we here alone or not and so
this really gets that kind of
that second one which is um you know is
there other life
uh whether intelligent or not you know
elsewhere in in the galaxy
right right it's hard to believe that
there isn't
how you know big the the galaxy is i
mean
but yeah i mean i it's hard but what
type of life form that is who knows
you know there's more and more ufo uh
videos that are coming out from the air
force that are being dropped by saying
that they exist you know so
[Laughter]
[Music]
so uh you get to ask me one question to
uh to finish this up what's the one
question you have for me uh what do you
wanna be doing in five years
uh that's the easy one doing the exact
same thing i'm doing now i'm having a
blast
um i i always joke and i say uh people
will ask me like you know
how do you do all this stuff whatever
and i say it's because
it's fun for me right and there will be
a day and then i
get the sense that you're probably
similar to me where like i just wake up
and i'm like okay this isn't fun
like it's over i'm not writing anymore
i'm not recording videos i'm not talking
about crypt like just it's over
uh and i want to go do something else
and um i don't really know
why that would happen or when that will
happen but
you just get this sense of like you
could do something for 5
10 20 maybe 30 years and then one day
you just say hey i want to go do
something else
but until that day comes i i just don't
see myself doing anything else because i
genuinely enjoy it right
what what's your north star with kind of
everything that you do what's the thing
that really just kind of drives you the
most
just learning i mean i i joke all the
time people who listen to podcasts
have heard me talk about a bunch but uh
this is like the most selfish thing i do
right and selfish because i get to talk
to a bunch of smart people who educate
me on stuff right so you just gave me a
master class on
micro cap stocks and i could have went
and read online for you know
hours but i probably learned more just
now than i would have uh doing that
and so um i think people genuinely
appreciate the fact that like i record
the conversations i put them out i'll
write about them and kind of
you know create a bunch of content
around it but ultimately like i'm
learning
right and so once you kind of have um a
bunch of this
it helps inform my own investment
decision making right so whether it's
venture capital it's you know more than
crypto stuff
um it just you're you're getting so many
smart people telling you so much stuff
that yeah sure you throw some of it out
but there's a lot that sticks too
right and you also are able to do
pattern recognition which to me
when you go to that kind of north star
of learning that's actually probably
what you
learned the most right is like whether
you talk to a micro cap investor a large
cap investor a venture capitalist
whatever
like hey the team matters okay like
like you know pretty elementary level
type thing but
getting that reinforced by people who
invest in all different aspects of
a financial market um i think just kind
of you know hammers at home
um and so i do look at almost like an
advantage right
that uh that i get kind of a diversity
of um of people and experiences um that
i get to just ingest every day
so thank you no no i mean i think you do
amazing job and i think the way you
do it is really good because i kind of
think um in one way
you crush it in a lot of ways but one
way that i think it's kind of similar
what you and i do
is you know a lot of people at least
historically probably have looked at
bitcoin
and crypto and at least the traditional
financial folks be like oh
you know that guy or they're doing that
it's the same way people look at
microcap or penny stocks
and you try to bring credibility to what
you're doing by
you know first and foremost just being
intelligent what you say and the people
you bring on your podcast
and things like that and it just brings
you know credibility to everything that
you do but credibility to you know
whether it's crypto or bitcoin or
microcap
you know these are these are asset
classes that should have
um more people looking at them in an
intelligent
matter you know so i think what you're
doing is amazing and look there's a
balance right like i always joke with
people i say like hey i want everyone to
know about bitcoin and understand it but
at the same time like maybe just wait a
couple of years before you guys all get
smart on it right because that's the
opportunity
same thing with micro cap right as if
every investor in the world was looking
at micro cap
actually that would be a bad thing for
you right yeah it'd be a much more
efficient market
well it's unfortunate that the same the
same rules apply too like right now
microcap is probably hitting its peak on
awareness just because there's a lot of
small cap microcap momentum plays
whether they're covered plays whether
they're
whatever it is that are just making
really stupid you know going up 500 a
thousand percent and
a few days to a few weeks you know and
so you get more attention when things
are rising
um and the same thing probably happened
with what in your world you know a
couple years ago it'll happen again
it's unfortunate that more people will
look at it you know at the
probably the wrong time but you know
whatever you know overall everything's
going to go ebb and flow
absolutely where can we send people to
uh to learn more about you
and microcap club or other things you
want them to go check out
um you can find me on twitter my handle
is my name ian castle
you can go to microcapclub.com that's a
good
good resource for microcaps awesome man
well listen thank you so much for taking
the time to do this like
like i said uh you know i learned a lot
today i hope everyone else did and
we'll have to do this again in the
future thanks bang bang